ou la martinique le sergent moutama il
vient d'être nommé
donation cité à l'ordre de la nation et
qui est décédé malheureusement en
intervention
quelques mois sur
lors d'une intervention sur le prêcheur
feu de broussailles chercheurs tels que
nous avons pu abolir
aujourd'hui les pompiers sont toujours
pas toujours sur le front bien
évidemment refusé
sur le front du président joliment son
blason était très impliqué dans la phase
j'allais dire plus paroxysmique nous
avons eu le cas par jour
nous sommes entre en deux ans une
situation quasiment plus de
invention vivre encore quelques cas qui
sont déclarés du personnes qui
étranger mais nous restons mobilisés
puisque nous ne savons pas comment les
choses et nous sommes bien sûr très
mobilisés préparer la sauce critique
parce que voilà un grand prix en cache
une autre
et nous ne sommes pas à l'abri d'une
situation de fait je rappelle que le
dernier phénomène cyclonique dates 2007
sit-in comme depuis la martinique pas
connu de frein est situé route même si
beaucoup ont ce passé proche de nouri
notamment devant le 17 et que la
martinique n'a pas non plus depuis 50
ans connue de cyclones majeurs à savoir
une catégorie 4 ou de là donc il faut
vraiment dépit du fait que je comprends
que tout le monde soit 26 au gel mais il
faut néanmoins que tout se mobilise
toutes les énergies se mobilisent pour
se préparer parce qu'il ya que si nous
somme qui paraît comment faire face
correctement
qu'est ce qu'on peut ressentir même
quand on est occupé à 2
sapeurs pompiers aux côtés forcément
beaucoup d'émotion ce qui est un parti
très proche de lui qui est
voilà quasiment se sont retrouvés bas
passer d'une situation et notre retrait
brutal
malheureusement c'est nous qui sommes un
petit peu préparé mes concerts nous
touche même
ça me rappelle que nous sommes bien
vulnérable dans ces situations bien sûr
ça nous renforce dans notre cohésion
nous demander notre vision ça nous
oblige à faire autour d'expériences on
et comprendre qu'est ce qui s'est passé
comme on peut
colas néant éviter les situations
peuvent engendrer
malheureusement d été
des mouvements comme celui là ils sont
ravis mais néanmoins nous sommes bien
conscients que nous sommes des hommes
sont engagés dans des situations qui
sont à risque
en sorte de les maîtriser au mieux
nous devons faire ensemble des baies du
hall 1